the last of us developer Naughty Dog has
outlined it to release plans beyond the
upcoming PlayStation 4 exclusive
uncharted for a thieves n saying it has
at least one more game for current-gen
consoles in an interview with finder
community strategist aren Maier was
asked whether the first party so nice to
do plans to make another title for the
company's current gen console I would
hope we released a game pretty soon our
development cycles aren't too long and I
have no idea how long this console
generation really is going to last but
yeah there's no doubt it should be in
this console generation for sure Meyer
was presented with concerns regarding
the length of the current generation
given that Nintendo is already preparing
to lease a follow-up to the wii u Meyer
went on to say I don't know what the
timelines are but naughty dog has at
least one more maybe two games left in
this console generation maybe more
clearly we can release a game really
late into the console generation and do
well right in September Naughty Dog's
creative director Neil druckmann said a
prototype for the last of us to was made
but a sequel is not currently in
development at the studio when Bruce and
I moved over to uncharted 4 we were
brainstorming ideas for the last of us
to with characters ideas from the last
of us with Joel and Ally ideas for a
sci-fi game ideas for a fantasy game and
building prototypes for each one of
these he explained and just when we were
getting close to settling or narrowing
that list down we were asked to work on
uncharted for later that month
PlayStation boss Shuhei Yoshida
confirmed Naughty Dog is brainstorming
ideas for a sequel but the project is
not yet confirmed and may not appear for
a while what do you hope to see next
another last of us may be a new jak and
daxter or something new entirely
you